Mila is one of three Canadian
research institutes in AI.
And our goal is to be a global pole
for scientific advances
that inspires innovation and the development
of AI for the benefit of all.
Mila is a community of a thousand people.
So to make that work, you need
some shared values.
Some of the core values that are shared here
are around rigour, excellence,
collaboration, innovation, diversity,
inclusion and many more.
There are four main pillars
to what we do and who we are at Mila.
The first, which is really the core and
the genesis of Mila, is talent.
So attracting, retaining, training talent
that will have a broad...
spectrum of competencies in AI.
The second is scientific research,
scientific advances,
developing the science's technology
and doing it
really with standards that are shared
at a global scale.
The third piece is the adoption of AI.
Now, this gets interesting.
So how do we go from lab to enterprise?
From kind of the theoretic world
to the real world.
And here we talk about small enterprises,
start-ups, large organizations,
how do we partner with them
to facilitate that transfer?
And the fourth pillar is social influence.
It's this collective conversation we're in
around what is AI?
What role should AI play?
How do we develop AI in a socially
responsible and ethical way?
We need to remember
that this success we have today,
this institute we have today that
we're so proud of
really rests on decades of work and
on the shoulders of giants.
And so, part of what we need to do
is preserve this advantage,
preserve these bases, right?
But then, as we do that,
start identifying certain areas, certain domains
where AI can really make a big difference.
We think about health,
we think about the climate crisis.
And so, as these opportunities emerge,
how are we gonna capture them
and really allow AI
to realize its full potential?
The Canadian AI ecosystem is
incredibly healthy today.
When you look at some of these
global indexes,
Canada actually is fourth behind
China, the US and the UK.
So we're in a good position right now.
Part of what we need to do is make sure
that we consolidate that position,
that we don't lose track of the fundamentals
that have allowed us to have all of this success
and that we continue to do very,
very well what we were most known for.
And I think that's gonna be important,
part of it is gonna be talent,
part of it is gonna be investment,
part of it is gonna be a larger group of
enterprises, small, medium, large,
really taking on AI and understanding
what it needs for them.
And us collectively in Canada
and in Quebec certainly, deciding:
Okay, what do we want to do
with this AI potential?
How far are we willing to go?